um it's it's been great chatty and
that's the end of the video
i'm just kidding we're still here we're
actually gonna talk about what we were
talking about before
um if you've just joined the stream or
if you're watching the stream back
thanks for sitting through that five
minutes of me uh sitting about not
knowing what i was doing
basically what happened before this
stream i thought you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna test the streaming because i'm
planning on streaming dc fandom for all
you guys out there you know i love a dc
thing
so i thought i'd test it didn't realize
streamed the entire thing of me just
sitting there on my computer
thank god i was only looking at pictures
of batman that's all i'll say
because you should have seen what i had
on before um
but then you know this official logo it
is official
this got revealed so i thought you know
what
i'm gonna i'm gonna do a live stream
right now and just talk about it i've
been out all day
uh i'm actually giving myself the day
off because
uh dc phantom's gonna take up pretty
much most of my time on the weekend so i
thought you know i'll have i'll have a
day off
and i thought you know what i'll give
something back this has just come out
so oh thank you jesus judas as well
not a great name uh if i'm gonna be
honest but yeah thanks very much
and thank you everyone's checking in
brilliant
so this is the official batman logo
that picture as well is also drawn by
jim lee
now jim lee is the dc ceo you probably
know him from
comics and just doing amazing art
the first time i read a story by jim was
hush and
it was it was around about when i was 13
when i was growing up i absolutely loved
comics when i was about
four or five started getting a bit older
started thinking that they were for
losers
trying to fit in at school and then hush
came out in 2006
i think it was went to the comics shop
read
the second issue never never read the
first i don't know why i just picked up
the second issue
and i thought you know what this is
incredible i'm gonna i'm gonna start
reading these
and to see jim's stratospheric rise
where he's at now it's absolutely
brilliant
um so yes this is official
is this movie going to be very light and
funny apparently they're shooting for an
r rating
which is it's pretty big that when you
think about it
a batman film that's r-rated um
joker of course a lot of people didn't
think that would do very well but
i i absolutely loved it it's not one
that i go back to
um from last year probably prefer
end game i know i shouldn't say that in
a dc chat because it'll kick off but
brilliant film and i love the way that
dc
are just really giving their creators
free reign at the moment and saying
do what you want here's the money enjoy
yourself
i wish they would give some of that to
me i probably spent about
40 grand on buying dc comics over my
life and do i get anything back for it
do i
do a hell right yes the movie's gonna be
light and funny if you ask again
i've accidentally made someone a
moderator
it's all kicking off i tell you what you
can have it
yeah we're gonna put you in a bloody
timeout mate
so thanks very much for checking in
uh this is the big face reveal we've got
loads of stuff to talk about
so the batman logo as i was saying
before
this film is really they've
you can tell that they've just taken
everything from a top level view
and said how will this world work how
will things look
in a world that works like this and
they've just completely nailed it
you go back to things like batman and
robin you know the batmobile
looked a certain way the bat suit looked
a certain way
and stylistically these things i
personally think they didn't really mesh
that well whereas here
everything across the board really well
thought out you look at the bat suit
it's diy it's been put together clearly
by bruce wayne the bat bike
clearly being put together by bruce
wayne the um
the batmobile clearly being put together
by bruce wayne so what they're doing is
going for a very
very grounded feel for this film and
this is reflected perfectly in the logo
i think
a lot of people have criticized robert
pattinson for being too skinny
and this logo is skinny so again it's
that whole idea of
how will this world basically look and
how old things operate in it this batman
he's quite trimmed down
what would his logo look like and you
know juxtaposing that
the the logo for batman v superman very
bulky bat
bat symbol similar to the dark knight
returns ben affleck was big and bulky so
i know i'm probably breaking this down
far too much and it is just a logo
but clearly they've looked at robert
pattinson and thought you know he's a
trim guy
his logo needs to be trim so yeah
enjoying it
jim lee excellent drawing love the red
a lot of people have said that it's
basically
it's going to be similar to dark victory
and we've got a very interesting thing
to talk about in just a bit
so dark victory is basically a sequel to
the long halloween
but it's pretty much the same sort of
story now in
both the long halloween and dark victory
there's a
masked killer in gotham going around
sorting stuff out
killing people on certain dates happens
in the long halloween
and on specific dates such as father's
day
mother's day christmas day so
dark victory it does the same thing now
the color tone of dark victory is red
and black
an interesting thing that happens in
dark victory is that robin
shows up at the end and there's
something that we actually need to talk
about with that
so i'm going to get rid of the logo and
show you the next bit
so this was sent to me today
and what it is is a production suit used
for the batman movie apparently and
it's meant to be for robin now
i don't know if this is legitimate
clearly this guy
is making a lot of money if he's faking
stuff
but what it is is basically if you go on
his page he's got loads of movie props
from
behind the scenes stuff um there's lots
of special things like
batman battiers batman white eyes
don't don't tell anyone that yet but
yeah
so there is an idea here that robin
could be in the film
now this guy could be misleading
everyone uh
he could he could this could be his
underpants that he's selling
um and it's basically what it's meant to
be is part of a fabric that's part of
the robin suit
now we did hear rumors a while back that
robin was gonna be in the movie
personally i'm not a hundred percent
sure whether this is legitimate or not
and ebay aren't exactly the most
trustworthy place for
taking down fraud stuff you know i've
put a lot of uh
a lot of fake dvds on there over the
years
so what is interesting though
is the fact that they're going for a
very stylized dark victory
uh look towards the entire production
now in the dc fandom trailer we did see
that matt reeve is standing on a black
and red background and
the the logo today has pretty much just
confirmed that
you know this is going to be leaning
towards stark victory
robin makes his debut in dark victory
what happens is
bruce wayne goes to hayley circus uh i
think it's
a mobster called zuko should have looked
this all up
um but he's he meets
basically dick grayson then dick grayson
moves in with him and
what he brings to the table is a brand
new perspective
for bruce bruce is basically up until
that point just been
looking out for just doing it himself
he's a
there's a famous a famous phrase of no
man is an island which is often used
against bruce when he's
out he's like i just do this myself no
but robin
do you know do you want robin i come
come help you no i don't i don't like
kids
so could be a robin
thing popping up now zuko kills robin's
parents
spoiler alert robin gets adopted by
bruce wayne
because alfred pretty much forces him to
say look mate yeah
you keep going out on night dresses
about do you not think you're a bit
mental
i brought a kid in he's gonna help and
what robin does is
basically the killer is called hangman
and he leaves clues by
leaving hang man stuff you know the game
hangman so you leave blank letters
and one of them says look what the
reader does as well is they guess what
the clues are and it
it says none of you are safe batman is
he's
obsessing over this for months and
months and months eventually you let's
robin in
robin says look mate i'm a kid i'm
looking at this from a different angle
it says
nine of you are safe so yeah
could be robin i hope i don't know if it
is i might just buy this
for for a laugh and his name is tony's
ago
so yeah thank you very much now uh
we've got another thing to talk about
and also yeah thanks everyone for
joining in sticking with this stream
because
it is a bit of a mess um i wasn't
expecting it to
to be going streaming today but i just
thought you know what i'm going to test
this out before i do dc founder because
there'll be about 10 people watching
that and i need to make sure that it
looks great for them
so you should hopefully be able to see
the new snyder cut trailer
coming up soon which i'm just going to
get everything set up for it
i did have this uh this early
but you know with uh we've kind of
messed this entire thing up
a bit here i've just deleted all my
graphics as well oh no
so i'll just uh
whoa trippy or what
i will hang around at the end to answer
your questions if you want
now hopefully i'm gonna wait and make
sure this works first before doing it
but you should be able to see the uh the
justice league
clip there's not really much going on in
it but i thought we'd talk about it
so this has just dropped today um you
have superman there standing at the
basically his gravesite now this was
shown at the end of batman v superman
and they put down a symbol for him and
wrote the words in chalk if you
seek his monument look around you he's
returning back
i look you know i'll tell you what else
is good it's blue
the entire film looks blue well we know
snyder wanted to make this as blue as
possible
and then joss whedon came in made
everything red at the end
looks much better like this uh that is
clearly the smash statue as well that
superman was thrown into
when he was fighting doomsday so his
last memory
probably would have been throwing be
getting thrown towards that statue
uh getting you know killing doomsday and
getting killed at the same time
then black then he wakes up flies out
drops down here sees if you seek his
monument look around you
now one one thing i never quite thought
was that convincing
in the uh the justice league theatrical
cut was that superman
went crazy and then all of a sudden next
scene after he saw lois he was fine
it didn't really work for me that much
so to see him standing here
looking at what the people have thought
of his death
because you have to remember when
superman was alive in batman v superman
everyone hated them they were doing news
reports about north slagging them off
they're going
up next you know it's superman and we
don't like um
what about you weatherman and the
weatherman would be like that's not a
superhero
called weatherman by the way it's just
the weather man the weather man was like
oh
he's there was a there was a thing last
weekend
he saved that woman off a ripped rooftop
in a storm
rubbish they hated him so him coming out
here you know he's angry he's not really
knowing what's going on he's been dead
he's seen this and he's probably gonna
remember you know maybe people
did miss me you know i mean sometimes i
don't post for a day
and the next day everyone's like oh i
thought you i thought you weren't coming
back oh i love you
please do a terrible live stream where
the audio stumbled up we'll do anything
so yeah great to see it next scene
victor stone you could clearly see on
his jersey
jersey stone you know which team he's
playing for
the gotham rogues where were the gotham
rogues batman v
superman so love it uh this is just
before the car crash that happens for
him that kills him
uh spoiler alert so he's cheering he's
one
and basically what happened was
his mother and father woman by the way
spoilers here i haven't put a spoiler
warning out yet but what happened uh
was this is in the the original snyder
cut of justice league
victor stone it's his big game it is big
game night you know
he he wants his mom and dad there like
my mom and dad i invited them to this
stream and they didn't show up
he wants his mom and dad there guess who
guess who doesn't go
he's bloody dad why doesn't his dad go
because he's working in the lab
again building killer robots as you do
anyway he goes he wins the game the
a guy comes out he's like i'm going to
sign you to the biggest football league
in the whole town
you don't need to play for the crappy
gotham rogues again who got beaten by
the metropolis guys in
batman v superman you might remember
there's a little easter egg for you
he goes that's great where's my dad
turns around isn't there his mom sat
there oh
again he's not showed up again typical
dad mr promises
so what he does he goes home in the car
with his mom
by the way ma'am is basically english
for
mother he goes home in the call with his
mother gets into an argument oh
dad my dad's never there he's always
gone out for a pack of smokes and he
never comes back
his mother's like she works really hard
in the lab building killer robots
you never know when you're gonna need to
be transformed into a killer robot
he's like oh and cyborg's like oh killer
robots are rubbish ah
cause there's a car crash boom guess
what happens
he wakes up in the lab is dad
he's like i'm building a killer robot
out of you this time
if i didn't build your killer robot then
you'd be dead
so this is this is going to be what's
going to happen in the movie this is
like
line full i've read this script uh
cyborg like oh well
you if you had been there my mother
wouldn't have died and basically it
fleshes out the drama a lot more
in the theatrical cut we we kind of got
teasers towards that and little hints of
it as
cyborg said his dad you know he was a
monster
they're going all out here they're
showing victor stone playing the game
they're showing what he was actually
like so we can relate to him as a human
whereas snyder cut didn't no sorry
the weeden cut or justice league as it's
called
didn't really feel like there was that
much in it that really made you relate
to cyborg
here we're seeing he had a great life
ruined by his dad who then turned him
into a robot
robocop robot cop as i call it
you then go um the guy who played jimmy
olsen
now this cameo was originally cut you
might remember in the original snyder
cut trailer
that this car goes hurtling towards him
cyborg jumps in the way and goes
you should probably move that was cut
from the film
and the guy who played jimmy olsen in
the original 1978
superman movie he got put as the
security guard
in the prison when the flash you know
the flashy draws he draws on that guy's
face with a pen super fast and then he
he grabs a woman and chokes and wb never
address it
that was basically his cameo
now originally it was the cop and what
happened
was lois lane every morning she got up
went down to superman's grave as we saw
in the montage
and this cop would be there and he would
talk in talking
to hey bring a coffee go like you know
you always come down here and see this
this dead superman's grave thing have
you got much of a life
you're quite an attractive lady and
you're always messing around down here
and she's like
oh you know i just had a thing going on
with superman
again these are lines in the script
and that would set up his cameo so
later when he appears here and cyborg
saves him it makes more sense this is
when superman's going wild he's throwing
cars about he's like
uh i hate i loved it when i was dead
there was a lot less to worry about you
woke me up in 2020 and it's rubbish
so this is what that basically is there
uh you then got the feet dropping down
get found with google ads no i will not
i want anyone to find me they should see
my live streams
and we officially know that the movie is
now going to be called the snyder cut
originally you know it was called zack
snyder's justice league and this was
purely down to legal issues
looks like warner brothers have slapped
them lawyers on people and said look
we're calling it what we want
so yeah tell you what you better i've
i've been head-to-head with those warner
brother lawyers and i tell you what they
did they took one look at my funko pop
collection
and were like this guy better not mess
with him
but yeah that's the official title for
it now
we're gonna hang around a bit thanks
everyone for sticking with me
this was a pretty bad stream in my
opinion but you know first time for
everything
i did the joke before about it's similar
to another time
first time i did something that was also
a flop
so yeah so what are people's thoughts on
it
so jimmy olsen um he thought captain
erie
i thought jimmy olsen was killed in bbs
in the the desert scene
when i say jimmy olsen it's purely
because i forgot the guy's name
so in the 1978 superman film the
character who played the guy who played
the character jimmy olsen he's popping
up here just as an easter egg
i don't think he's going to be called
jimmy olsen mark mcclure
i'm sure it's mark mcclure i think he's
playing jimmy olsen it's just a cameo
it's not the guy from
batman v superman that got shot in the
head within the first five minutes
just a cameo so
this stream is bad yeah i know
uh yeah so this is it
anyone got any questions
i got i did get the script yeah
i tell you what the spoiler man you
should see the things i know that i
don't talk about
i actually got sent them a lot of big
batman spoilers that
i'd get in trouble for you might
remember that i did have a um
halloween kills breakdown got blocked by
universal
and that was purely because i spoiled
the entire movie
it happens so i have got an instagram
it's at definition yt
thank you christian i do look really
professional with the tablet
yeah and zack snyder's parademons are
going to be different they're going to
be changed up a lot design wise um and
it's
the same sort of thing with steppenwolf
if you don't know basically steppenwolf
was originally meant to look
a lot more like he did at the end of
that might be superman in the hologram
and warner brothers
mid-production stepped in and said look
the problem with the problem with how
warner brothers handled the entire thing
and i'm going to go off on a bit of
around here
was they commissioned zack snyder to
basically build their universe
and he did man of steel did all right
performed all right critically performed
all right at the box office
not amazing but they thought you know
what there's groundwork here for us to
really
run things so back to back they thought
we've got to catch up to marvel
we're going to make batman v superman
and justice league pretty much film back
to back
and the they did start production very
fast
batman v superman came out we all know
what happened
i really love the ultimate edition
walked out of the theatrical edition
not very happy when our brothers started
thinking
oh my god we've just given
more money to a guy who this if this
happens again with justice league that's
all or universe ruined so what they did
was
they try to make it more like marvel and
this was mid production
it's very difficult to change something
when you're in the middle of it much
like this stream
joss whedon obviously directed the
avengers very
i don't want to talk about him
personally because i know there's a lot
going on at the moment
uh but when it comes to writing dialogue
you know he wrote
for toy story buffy
when it comes to writing dialogue i can
see why they hired him to do this
project
and make things more like marvel because
obviously he basically
made the avengers the success so that it
brought him in and they they changed
everything including the design of
steppenwolf including the parademons
introduced that russian family it did
did the thing with
henry cavill's mustache not very good
yes we are getting the original power
demons back thank you very much
no hbo max is not launching in the uk um
and also because i think it's launching
it on a streaming service
in france as well a completely different
one to hbo max so i don't think we will
be getting it over here
and i did request lovecraft country
episodes early because i know that the
the first five episodes were given to
people but in order to get them you have
to have
basically an hbo max account
it was the worst stream ever but you
know
[Music]
i don't not like you that was the i
don't
i don't not like you unfortunately that
line won't be in the snyder cut which is
a shame because as you know i've read
the script
and lex yeah lex does have a smaller
role
um lex luthor again was another part
that warner brothers
looked at and thought you know not not
that good we don't really like it that
much
and yes i will be busy on sunday not the
worst stream
thanks i'm happy with that not not the
worst stream
now my wife's actually just uh text me
and said that my food's ready
so i tell you what we'll we'll wrap this
up
next 10 questions i'll answer
and try not to go off on a big rent
i messed it up again
right yeah it should be definition yt if
it's not it's heavy spoilers
what am i most excited for at dc fandom
the batman
um definitely most excited for that but
then
probably second place is suicide squad
i'll full screen this so doesn't look as
bad
do i think microsoft should buy warner
brothers no um
i don't really like corporations coming
in and controlling everything
i think at t have done a great job so
far they've greenlit the snyder cut
they've they've they're throwing dc
fandom
i think they do i'm really really happy
with att
is joker going to be in the snyder cut
no not from what i know
um joker was a completely different
entity
uh even though it was jared leto i don't
think he's gonna be
in do you think
the schneiderker or hbo will make any
revisions to bvs and
like the snyder cup no
i think bbs is pretty much how it is you
might remember a couple of years ago
when it released on itunes they actually
did a thing where they cleaned up all
the digital noise on it so that it
looked more in line with joss whedon's
justice league
i think we're going to see a return to
the mcgritty and grainy
just um batman v superman so yeah
that'll be it
the stream does need more puns i just
don't want to pun
issue do you think dc can really recover
from its first start yes definitely
uh joker's shown that obviously joaquin
phoenix won
best actor at the oscars uh
aquaman grossed a billion i think wonder
woman did
batman i can see that gross in a billion
uh joker grossed a billion
i think they're easily going to catch up
especially with the way that marvel is
at the moment marvel are pretty much at
square one again
uh they've just had to relaunch their
universe pretty much they're carrying
things across but as far as characters
they all kind of exited
in end game the big ones at least bought
spider-man so i do think that dc
have the perfect opportunity to and the
height behind this event that also shows
that they
they definitely can do it
what dc characters would you like to see
next get their own movie
nightwing definitely
batman why eyes uh there are rumors that
there's going to be a second suit in the
movie
if there's a second suit i think it will
have the white eyes
is green latin gonna be in the side
occur apparently so and it might have
been army hammer who filmed it
we don't know for definite but the the
script leaks do say
that green lantern showed up at the end
as did martian manhunter
yeah bbs is different on itunes well it
was anyway
it didn't have any of the grain over the
top and the color palette was a lot
brighter
and that was to be more in line with
justice league
will the battle with the jail be longer
probably because it's got that mark
mcclure cameo in
so i imagine that it's going to be a lot
longer
blue beetle or booster go and booster
gold sorry i thought that was a question
yeah and unhinged is really good alex
reader really really good i went to see
a couple of weeks ago
very very good do you think flash will
get a new suit towards the end
i don't know yeah i think you'll have a
new suit for the flash movie
and i don't know whether they're going
to introduce that at the end i'd say
probably not and they'll probably leave
it for the flash movie
okay and this is gonna be the last
question
which i'll pick at random
your ideal casting choice for john
stewart greenland
idris elba would have been but i think
he's too old now
michael b jordan would uh would be great
i think
and the script of the snyder i didn't
actually read the the script i just read
the plot points i was lying before when
i said those lines of dialogues
weren't it and i think we're going to
leave it there guys thank you very much
for
stopping by sorry this video was a bit
of a mess i know
my competition's probably out there
right now cheering that it went crap but
have a good day take care